we'll the entities that you imagine will
their actions be judged morally we use
will eight will they be capable of good
and evil or will those categories be
retired once we get to doing these
complicated operations if I have to make
a guess those categories will probably
be replaced by something subtler idea
you would say that it's all yes isn't it
really
but that thing those creatures don't
will not have the sense of humor that
vote on and sequel in Siegfried then may
the Valkyrie he becomes a very subtle
bitter but very humorous figure or maybe
this world is is a joke
created by one of these super human eyes
we don't know what that we don't know
what their burden of proof here is for
you to prove that not for me to deny it
I mean I think in terms of the proof of
a technology that doesn't exist yet I
mean that that can't be offered and
until the moment the Wright brothers
made their planes fly that we're leading
scientists saying it would never happen
literally the week before it happened so
I mean that we're not gonna prove that
some new technology is going to come
about to the satisfaction of skeptics
but what what one thing I I do want to
clarify though is my best guess of how
the future will turn out is not that all
humans will be annihilated and and will
not exist any further and I think that
there there can be superhuman super
minds that are far beyond anything we
can conceive and there can also be a
eyes of roughly human level intelligence
that exists in the human world and that
help people so that the way I conceive
the opportunities that will be open to
humans in the future is they're just
very rich and diverse I mean one one
opportunity you can plug your brain into
this super human mind matrix and in
effect become part of some trans human
God mind thus losing yourself and
individuality and humanity but
let me finish because we keep getting
hung up on this point but I think there
will also be an opportunity to continue
living a human life in much the same
form as now except with a whole AI
driven infrastructure that will 3d print
any physical object that you want that
will cure any any disease that you may
get and that will regulate things the
people don't blow each other up and such
and know when humans who remain humans
continue to act like humans and do evil
things will the these super creatures
will they prevent them I mean will they
invade Syria to stop Assad so the way
nobody knows but the way I think about
it as humans will be sort of like the
squirrels in the National Park meaning
we don't interfere with the love lives
of the squirrels in the park and if one
squirrel bites the others head off we
don't necessarily stop them because we
view that is like that's what squirrels
do right but if you need to find a
better way the point is if there's a
plague in the park then the Ranger will
come in and cure the plague right so or
if the earth there's a forest fire we
will put out the fire so I mean I mean
if there's if there's something extreme
happening then the more intelligent
being overlooking the situation will
intervene because we don't care that
much about whether one squirrel lives or
dies but we didn't want that species and
population to continue right so that
that's my best guess why is it relevant
to us in traditional monotheistic
theology in all three of them there
already were such beings they were
called angels and if you study the
history of angelology which I don't
recommend but if you study the history
of angelology you see that the religious
kind of religious imagination was
obsessed with the not the increasing
perfection of the angels with the
hierarchies of the angels with the super
angels with the a plus one angels with
the a for you know the angel
intelligence angels and so on but the
thing about the angels was
that they had nothing to do with the
moral or spiritual life of human beings
they were simply a higher class of
entities with more direct access to the
Godhead I I can't describe it any more
because frankly I don't know what most
of the time they're talking about the
City of God at one point yet which has
many strange creatures in it but as as
far as I know if there's ever actually
existed in the human world they're
they're gone by now whereas the AI is
I'm talking about we could actually
build in the same sense that we built
this phone it built a tower built a
subway car so there that's a significant
difference right
you